the onyx logic metagenomics program will
be starting very soon
in this online program we will explore
the amazing role microbes play in the
environment
human health and disease designed to be
equally rewarding to students and
researchers the program will cover the
main aspects of microbiome studies
using next generation sequencing
overview of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of microbiome composition and
species richness
as well as other aspects of microbiology
research
using bioinformatics during this program
you will also
have the opportunity to apply
bioinformatics analysis methods
to research projects analyzing data
from the public domain and learning from
high impact biomedical publications
on relevant topics metagenomics is the
study of microbial communities in their
original living places
but many approaches to study these
communities allow for various levels of
resolution and
functional annotation so in this program
we will discuss
how the 16s ribosomal rna gene
amplicon studies hypervariable region
amplification
or even whole metagenomic sequencing and
even meta transcriptome studies
are revealing the significance of
microorganisms
all around us
to achieve this goal we constructed
a carefully designed program that
combines
interactive sessions self-guided study
materials that you can access
in a synchronous fashion as well as many
practical assignments
using both a visual interface and coding
practical assignments in the online
coursework
you will dive into the world of the
microbiome with this three-course series
introduction to metagenomics where you
will familiarize yourself
with the way microbiomes influence their
hosts and compose a unique community
which we can study using next-generation
sequencing
metagenomics one will focus on the
impact of bacterial diversity on human
health
where you will learn about multiple
types of sequencing methods
and then practice analysis using the
user-friendly t-binding for platform
and metagenomics 2 which builds on
previous courses to discuss 16s amplicon
sequencing studies
and the data2 analysis pipeline
specifically designed
for the analysis of these kinds of data
sets
in the course you will get a detailed
overview of
key topics important terminology
as well as a detailed and technical
overview
of the methods applied to these kinds of
data sets
the interactive tbionfor platform allows
you to process
analyze and integrate big data with no
coding
so we will learn how to apply some of
the tools on the platform
to study 16s microbial rna
you will find that on the interface of
the tibial
platform you can easily find the
relevant methods
with detailed explanations of what each
step of the method does
to allow us to study the microbiome
composition
and diversity we will also go further
and look at how we can use popular
methods of analysis
as well as visualization to understand
interpret
and visualize microbial community data
to learn about metagenomics we will
discuss what the microbiome is
how we can use next generation
sequencing to study
whole microbial communities and analyze
individual microbial genomes we will
also discuss
data sets or projects that are available
for analysis and study
of the role microbes play in agriculture
biomedical research topics and even
epidemiological studies
of infectious and chronic diseases
16s amplicon sequencing is a
recently developed and popular technique
that is widely used
to study micron directly in its
environment
so we will discuss how the bacterial 16s
ribosomal gene contains specific
hypervariable regions
that allow us to study different levels
of taxonomy
these levels of taxonomy are based on
annotated databases where we can find
metagenomic sequences
and link hypervariable regions to aid
in taxonomic classification so we will
apply this kind of analysis to a variety
of different projects for example
in the american gut project we will see
how the citizen science project
that is dedicated to metagenomic
sequencing of world citizens
who are contributing their microbiome
samples to allow researchers to
understand
microbiome variability and association
with particular traits
we will also look at some untrivial
relationship between the microbiome
the human immune system as well as the
anxiety
that is caused specifically by microbial
composition
then we will focus on individual members
of some of these microbial communities
that
are highly pathogenic cause chronic
conditions
or even affect different aspects of
crop production i welcome you to join
armex logic metagenomics we will have a
total of six
interactive sessions you will get
support from our trained
mentors and be able to participate
in group projects to analyze data sets
interpret them and develop a
presentation
based on what you have learned